Rachel when when you were just a little
younger than Margaret you wanted to be a
professional ice skater which I did not
know
yeah for a second I had to bring it up I
was like that's like that's like
something we all dreamed but never
actually did like I didn't do it either
yeah you were scared yeah yeah yes I
wasn't very professional but yes I was I
was a skater I skated from 4 to 17 until
I went to theater school that's a skater
4-17 I'm like I did it like once a year
with all my friends and we fell down
like nobody actually ever did it that's
what did did you actually have a real
dream of wanting to do it professionally
I did for a time yeah yeah when I was
younger yeah and funny enough I hit
puberty and everything goes
somewhere and you know it's like doing
jumps was like oh yeah it wasn't
flinging myself around the ice the way I
was yeah but um but no it you know to
become a you know a champion ice skater
you have to start really really young it
was like okay you want to do that you
move away from your family and you
um get tutored on the ice every day and
um this I was gonna do pears skating so
I would have so there's another boy who
was nine we were both nine years old I
was like he will become your everything
um well that's like an array like an
arranged marriage and then we won't
really know if you're any good until
you're about 14. when you both have gone
through puberty and we see if it's all
still working who would who says yes to
that opportunity that seems like not a
fun time no I was like yeah you were
like I'm okay when did you when did you
know you wanted to act when did that hit
you
um I was I was pretty young yeah I was
probably about seven or eight wow yeah
yeah I wrote my parents a letter saying
I wanted to be on Ed McMahon's Star
Search yes I was in a later version
yeah I didn't know I wanted to sing like
everybody's saying where I grew up so I
didn't really know until I was like a
teenager like I was like 13 yeah and I
was just like and I knew I like to sing
but I know I could actually do it you
know from Castle town so like yeah so
that's incredible to know that young you
knew very young as well yeah I did still
young I I am yes
um but both my parents are both actors
as well so I would go into their
auditions with them and I would sit on
the producer's couch and I just watch
them and be like and then one day when I
was about three and a half I was just
like hey I want to do this now when can
I get an audition please keep me with
your agent
um yeah my daughter so they got me with
their agent and I went up for a
commercial and I got it and I had to
sing a little song about Chevrolet and
it was on my fourth birthday and I shot
it on my fourth birthday so my birthday
is my ACT again your first paying gig
was at four yeah
that's incredible yeah so Judy did you
ever want to be anything other than a
writer did you know I never wanted to be
a writer wait what I never knew that was
even a possibility no I love to read
growing up yeah but it never occurred to
me that you know that these people who
wrote the books were living awful yeah
yeah oh my gosh no and so what did you
what were some of your dreams like our
aspirations I wanted to be a cowgirl
okay you can still be one I can still be
one and I never rode a horse but I had a
bicycle okay and you know if that was a
horse yeah right you should wait you've
still never ridden a horse
now I know don't say you won't you
should do it oh pony rides I had pony
rides in the park okay I was gonna say
no that's it's an amazing feeling yeah
that's a really good no but my
stepdaughter has lots of horses oh okay
many horses so I have horses in my
family okay hop on one one day it's fine
stay on though I have fallen off in my
tailbone
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody